>> MIKE: Hi. I'm Mike and I'm here with Daniel
and Romain. We're all engineers from the Android
team. And we're going to be introducing a
concept called applications without borders.
With Android, applications can integrate features
and data from other applications. They can
also use all of the hardware sensors on the
device including GPS, compass, accelerometer,
and the camera. And, of course, they can also
use all of the content available through Web
APIs. Now, Daniel's application is a really
good example of this.
>> DANIEL: I'm one of the engineers working
on Zebra Crossing, an open source library
to decode barcodes using a camera phone. We
have a great client for Android which really
shows off how we can integrate with the system.
So here's the application running using the
camera preview. Now, I'm going to scan a product.
There we go. And I can open product search
by sending an Intent. We can also recognize
2D barcodes called QR Codes. Let me show you.
So here's my business card which has a barcode
on the back. And when I scan it, I get my
contact info. So you can add me as a contact
without having to type it out or if I cancel
it out of there. You can do a few other things.
You can dial a number using the dialer, or
you can send an email to my address.
My app also publishes Intents so that other
applications can scan barcodes, too.
>> ROMAIN: I found this really useful and
I decided to integrate it into my own application
without doing their work. This is a list of
books that I keep with me in my pocket at
all times. And I want it in a way to be able
to quickly and easily add new books to my
library. So when you click the add menu, I
simply fire in the Intent that starts Daniel's
application. And I can now scan a book to
add it to the library. And once the book is
scanned, the application downloads information
about the book on the Internet. So really
here, I created a match up that leverages
features of both of our application to create
a richer user-experience. Now, Mike will show
you a different kind of match up.
>> MIKE: Now, my application mixes together
user creative content from the web along with
compass and GPS information and then an embedded
map view all into a kind of a geosocial stew.
So we're going to start by launching the application.
And when it comes up, we see an embedded map
view. This is showing the area that I'm going
to use to search for pictures, and it's centered
on my current location using GPS. When you
hit the search button, it goes out to the
Panoramio web service and finds the most popular
photographs that were taken in this area.
Now, here we have a picture of the T-Rex skeleton
that's on Google's campus. Don't ask. When
you click on that, you get more details about
that photo. And if you want to find where
that actually is in the real world, you have
two choices: you can either click on the map
menu and that will bring up a custom map view
that has a push pin with the physical location
of where that picture was taken; and it also
shows your location using GPS. And if you
want to navigate there by walking, you can
hit the radar view and that will give you
a bearing to that statue, to that skeleton.
So the T-Rex is 200 yards that way. We hope
that these demos have shown that with Android
you can think about application development
on a fundamentally different way. We've already
seen examples where developers are building
on each other's work to combine features in
exciting new ways. And we can't wait to see
what you come up with.